WAI CHEE DIMOCK: For
now, I just want to
give you some biographical
details that might be a kind
of interesting parallel to
basically the entire
body of work by
Fitzgerald that we're seeing.
Last time, we already saw that
Fitzgerald was married to
Zelda Sayer.
And she was basically the social
center in Montgomery,
Alabama where he
was stationed.
So he referred to her as the
first American flapper.
So obviously that has resonances
for the story
"Bernice Bobs Her Hair." We
know that that is where he
gets part of his inspiration.
And he has other stories
about flappers.
As we know, he has a whole
collection called Flappers and
Philosophers.
So Zelda has been there pretty
much from quite early on in
the short stories.
But really, the work in which
Zelda has the most important
presence is Tender
is the Night.
So just some interesting
details,
some interesting parallels.
Some of you might have been
surprised that Nicole refers
to Dick as Captain Diver when
she writes to him from the
sanatorium.
And it's not really very well
accounted for, because Dick,
in fact, did not really fight.
He was considered too valuable
to be lost in battle.
So he was in Switzerland, and
he was not in combat.
But Nicole refers to him
as Captain Diver.
And in turns out that this is a
kind of interesting personal
connection to Fitzgerald's
own life and
his relation to Zelda.
It turns out that in the
Fitzgerald collection that I
was talking about last time
at the University of South
Carolina, they have a couple of
very prized items in that
collection.
One is this briefcase saying
"F. Scott Fitzgerald, Fifth
Avenue."
And the other is this
hip flask with an
inscription from it.
And it turns out that this is
a gift from Zelda to Scott
before they were married, when
they were just courting.
And this is the inscription
on that flask.
"To 1st Lt.
F. Scott Fitzgerald, 65th
Infantry, Camp Sheridan,
Forget-me-not, Zelda,
September 13, 1918,
Montgomery, Ala."
So in turns out that the
military rank is a small
personal detail in
the courtship.
The attribution of military rank
that, in fact, was not
really the real professional
identity for
Fitzgerald at any point.
He was there.
He was in Montgomery.
He was not fighting either
in Montgomery, Alabama.
But she referred to him as 1st
lieutenant as the more
dignified title.
And we'll see that titles,
whether one is referred to as
Doctor or Mister, actually makes
a difference in Tender
Is the Night.
So from the very beginning, a
kind of title consciousness on
the part of Fitzgerald, I guess,
translated into Captain
Diver in Tender Is the Night.
But that's just a very,
very small connection.
The most important connections,
as some of you
might know, has to do with a
fairly long history, a long
and painful history of
mental instability
on the part of Zelda.
Basically from the 1930s on,
she never was not inside a
clinic at some point during
her career until she died.
She was in and out of mental
institutions, some more
luxurious than others.
Some not looking like a mental
institution at all.
So we'll begin with those.
Anyway, this is the reference
to him as Captain Diver in
Tender Is the Night.
But this is one of the first
that she when to.
I think it might even have
been the first, called
Prangins in Switzerland.
And we'll see a picture
of her room there.
That was in 1930.
And as you can see, almost like
a hotel room, not looking
like the ideal of a mental
institution, certainly.
Not the place where Darl would
go to when he goes to Jackson,
Mississippi.
So at the very other end
of the social spectrum.
That's where she started out
when she began her long career
of medicalization.
And this is the picture of her
release from Prangins.
And you can see that she
actually looks very different
from when she was 18.
Almost unrecognizable,
the two of them.
I guess it's separated by a
number of years as well.
But really looking very,
very different.
And I think that was the
earliest instance in 1930.
That was an unduly optimistic
diagnosis that she was
recovered, that she recovered
from the breakdown.
Because she was very soon
hospitalized again.
And this time in another even
more famous Swiss clinic,
Burgholtzi, which is where
Jung actually practiced.
And I think Freud actually was
there briefly as well.
So in Tender is the Night,
there's a reference to Freud
that Dick Diver's to get to
Vienna before Freud retires,
and there's also the
Swiss clinic.
So all of that is, in part, has
a connection to Zelda's
own medical history
in Switzerland.
And then she went to a
bunch of other ones.
I can't even keep track of
all the different one's
that she went to.
But at some point in 1932, she
went to Johns Hopkins.
They were back in
this country.
She went to Johns Hopkins
hospital.
And that turned out to have
quite an important effect on
both of them.
Because when she was at Hopkins,
part of the treatment
was that she would have to write
for two hours a day.
That was part of the
medical treatment.
So she started writing.
And she wrote a novel called
Save Me the Waltz, which was
published in 1932.
It was only about 1,000
copies sold.
So it didn't make its way into
American literature, exactly.
But it's interesting in many
ways, because it is Zelda
using her own medical history,
using her marriage to Scott
Fitzgerald, using all that
personal stuff as material for
this novel.
And Fitzgerald actually tried
to stop it from being
published or tried to revise it
very significantly before
it was published.
And then after it was published,
he had this opinion
about his wife's novel.
"Plagiaristic, unwise
in every way.
Should not have been
written. "
So this is, in may ways, a kind
of a long painful example
of the many, many instances in
American literature of the
husband having some control
over the wife's writing.
The most famous example is Ted
Hughes and Sylvia Plath.
Her letters were actually edited
by him after her death.
So in this case, she did
get it published.
But it didn't reach a very
wide audience, and he was
against it from day one.
The daughter, Scottie, had a
somewhat different opinion.
She just said that "this
sort of competition is
traditionally the bane of
literary romances." So at
least she had a very clear-eyed
view about the
marriage that there was quite
a competition going on.
Even though, obviously, he was
the one who was the writer.
she had some aspirations
as well.
And if she had been encouraged,
might actually
have had more of a career.
So the element of competition
between husband and wife I
think is quite an
important theme.
Even though Fitzgerald tried to
downplay it in saying that
his wife's the one who really
had no talent, she had to
plagiarize from him, he must
have registered the fact that
she was more of a competitor
than he let on.
So we'll see how that plays out
in the dynamics between
Dick Diver and Nicole
and who wins out.
This is actually not so
important, but just a kind of
point of reference is we know
there's another woman,
significant woman in Tender
is the Night,
Rosemary, the actress.
And I think this is generally
thought that this is the
person that Rosemary
is based on.
And we can sort of see that.
She has this very wholesome,
innocent look.
But she also was tremendously
disciplined as an actress.
And indeed, she had a
very distinguished
career as an actress.
So this is sort of the Hollywood
contribution to
Tender Is the Night.
Today's lecture actually will
be more about cinematic
techniques.
So even though she personifies
Hollywood's contribution to
Tender Is the Night, actually
it's in terms of formal
techniques that film would have
more of an input on the
narrative technique of
Tender Is the Night.
But I want to go back very
briefly to something that
we've been talking about all
semester, which is the very
important, and in many ways,
variously played out dynamics
between the "have" and the "have
not." So I know you guys
might not have gotten to the
end of this novel, so I
apologize, but there's really no
way I could talk about the
novel without talking
about the ending.
So without knowing all the
details in between, this is
the last two paragraphs of
Tender is the Night.
"...but he became entangled with
a girl who worked in a
grocery store, and he was also
involved in a lawsuit about
some medical question;
so he left Lockport.
After that he didn't ask for
the children to be sent to
America and didn't answer when
Nicole wrote asking him if he
needed money.
In the last letter she had from
him he told her that he
was practising in Geneva, New
York, and she got the
impression that he had settled
down with some one to keep
house for him.
She looked up Geneva in an atlas
and found it was in the
heart of the Finger Lakes
Section and considered a
pleasant place.
Perhaps, so she liked to think,
his career was biding
its time again like Grant's in
Galena; his latest note was
post-marked from Hornell, New
York, which is some distance
from Geneva and a very small
town; in any case he is almost
certainly in that section of
the country, in one town or
another."
So those last five words, five
of the cruelest words in
American literature.
He's a total nobody by
the end of the novel,
in one town or another.
So this is a novel that moves
very fast. We start out with
him at the top of his
profession, full of promise.
In fact, when we first see
him, he is idolized by
everyone around him.
To get there to this ending
that the woman in his life
would be someone that he sees
in a grocery store--
and not even that, getting
into trouble of his very
modest medical practice.
A drifter, going from one
small town to another.
And this additional insult that
he starts out in Zurich,
Switzerland --
a city that everyone
knows about --
to Geneva, New York, which
Nicole has to look up in an
atlas, and he can't even
hold onto this Geneva.
So it is, in many ways, the
ending is the beginning, but a
highly ironized beginning.
We've seen this structure
before, and I promise you
we'll see it one more time.
So the last three novelists that
we read basically have
the same structure, but to
totally different effect.
So from what we know at this
point, we know that at least
one other novel has this
circular structure-- the
ending is the beginning--
which is For Whom
the Bell Tolls.
So we've talked about this,
but just want to give you
those two sentences.
Beginning, "He lay flat on the
brown, pine-needled floor of
the forest." And then the last
line, "He could feel his heart
beating against the pine-needled
floor of the
forest."
So it is Hemingway's very tender
rendition of a life
that could be construed as the
life of a "have not." We
talked about that possibility
that maybe
he really has nothing.
All he has is a broken leg,
that very ironic reading,
which is not to be dismissed.
But against that ironic reading,
Hemingway invokes
this very lyrical image of
ending is the beginning as a
kind of an endless deferral
of the moment of death.
So he's still alive.
It's almost as if we're
beginning all over again.
And we, as the readers, want him
to begin all over again.
It is that illusion perpetrated
in our minds, the
reader's mind, that Hemingway is
able to write a novel that,
in some sense, doesn't really
have an ending.
In the ending is the beginning,
the actual death
scene is deferred to a
point of infinity.
So this is Hemingway's very
tender wrapping up of the life
of Robert Jordan in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
And in contrast to that,
Fitzgerald is about as
brutal as can be.
Actually, it's sort of
surprising that he would want
to be so thoroughgoing in the
degradation of Dick Diver.
But that's how he
wants to write.
So today we'll look at that
ending, the cruelty of that.
And link that to the question
of narrative speed.
We know that the novel is moving
very fast. A lot of
things have to happen for us to
get to that very, very low
point at the end of the novel.
So what has happened and what
does Fitzgerald have to do in
order to speed up the narrative
to such an extent
that he would get to that
absolute low point?
So last time, we talked about
montage and we talked about
flashback as two cinematic
techniques that are important
to Fitzgerald.
And today, we'll look at three
very, very common filming
techniques and the way that they
actually help to speed up
the narrative.
It's not self-evident that a
close-up would, in fact, speed
up the narrative.
But the way Fitzgerald uses his
close-ups actually does.
And it's not always clear that
cross-cutting would speed up
the narrative.
Once again, he uses this very
familiar technique to move
things forward.
And then we have the very fast
motion of the negative
resolutions.
Things being taken away
from Dick Diver.
So let's look at a couple of
instances of close-up.
And this is just so obviously
visual that it's sort of hard
to look away from that with
how to read this without
having some kind of
visual image.
This is about Rosemary.
As you know, she has this crush
on him, on Dick Diver,
and really desperately wants
to have an affair.
But it doesn't quite
happen for a while.
"Presently she kissed him
several times in the mouth,
her face getting big as it came
up to him; he had never
seen anything so dazzling as the
quality of her skin, and
since sometimes beauty gives
back the images of one's best
thoughts he thought of his
responsibility about Nicole,
and about the responsibility
of her being two doors down
across the corridor.
'The rain's over,' he said.
'Do you see the sun on the
slate?' Rosemary stood up and
leaned down and said her most
sincere thing to him.
'Oh, we're such actors --
you and I.'
OK, so we're starting out
on one kind of register.
We're starting with the notion
of Rosemary as this kind of
lovesick puppy that's
just pining for him.
And unrequited love on top of
that, that is going nowhere.
And so the first part up to the
last three lines of that
passage is really all about Dick
Diver being this noble
person, even though he could
have taken advantage of
Rosemary and she's
pining for him.
He could have easily taken
advantage of her.
He's not doing that.
He's thinking of his
responsibility to Nicole two
doors down the hall.
All that is really about the
nobility and anonymity and
uprightness of Dick Diver.
The last three lines swing us
to the other end, other side
of the narrative.
And all of a sudden, we
see what kind of a
person Rosemary is.
And she's completely truthful.
Rosemary's never not truthful.
Even though she's an actress,
she actually is the most
truthful person in the novel.
And this is an absolute
statement that is completely
right about both of them.
She is an actress.
So it's very hard to know where
the acting ends and
where the feeling begins.
She's so disciplined that she
would act in a certain way.
And then she runs into an
obstacle, and she stops acting
in that way as she was
doing right there.
It's like trying out one route,
seeing that is going
nowhere, and then suddenly
seeing that maybe she should
act in a different fashion.
So there is a way in which the
emotional life of Rosemary has
been completely professionalized
to such an
extent that she's always acting,
which is not even to
say that she's not sincere.
And Fitzgerald credits her
with being sincere.
It's just that that
is what she is.
I don't think that she is
capable of having any kind of
emotions outside of
her professional
identity as an actress.
So this is what she is.
So it is Dick's blindness to
that that he doesn't realize
that she's not exactly
a love-sick puppy.
She is someone who is
actually acting in
a particular fashion.
And who not only has a full
understanding of what kind of
a person she is, but
she has a full
understanding of what he is.
So it's not surprising that she
should know herself to be
primarily an actress.
It's not an accusation
to say that.
That's what she is.
Above everything else, she's
primarily an actress.
So she has that degree
of self-knowledge.
But she also has the knowledge
about him, that even though he
is supposedly a doctor,
he actually is,
at heart, an actor.
And that is an accusation, a
much more serious accusation,
directed at him than it is
directed at her, because she
has been totally up front.
She never is not an actress.
From the beginning of the
novel to the end, she is
defined by that.
He is supposed to be a doctor.
So he's not supposed
to be an actor.
But it turns out that maybe the
innermost truth about him
is that he is an actor.
And that all the appearance of
nobility, all the appearance
of uprightness, might turn out
to be an act that he is
putting up for her benefit.
An act that he's putting
up for his own benefit.
Sometimes we can act for
ourselves as well.
So it shows the degree of
knowledge of him and a
clear-eyed, unsentimental,
unlove-sick evaluation of
exactly what kind
of a man he is.
So it is the most acute
statement about Dick Diver
that we've seen up
to this point.
This is quite early, page 105.
So it is that acuteness, that
astute knowledge about a man
that she's supposedly idolizing
that gives the lie,
actually, to the adoration
that she seems to
be raining on him.
That it's actually completely
within bounds.
She's practicing what it's
like to be an adoring,
love-sick puppy.
She's acting that part.
But it's a part that she's
just doing it very well.
So just to move this to analysis
of the narrative
technique, the moment when we
have that kind of sudden
switch in perspective actually
comes with a visual detail
that her face is coming closer
and closer to him.
And her face is getting big
as it comes up to him.
So let's remember that one
visual detail that her face
completely fills his field of
vision, that he sees nothing
but her face.
So let's keep that one visual
detail in mind and see what
Fitzgerald does with that
detail, that close-up.
So this is another scene
quite a bit later--
actually a flashback.
So going back to the point when
Nicole was still in the
sanatorium and she was asking
him to take care of her.
"Nicole was up in her head now,
cool as cool, trying to
collate the sentimentalities
of her childhood, as
deliberate as a man getting
drunk after battle...
He breathed over her shoulder
and turned her insistently
about; she kissed him several
times, her face getting big
every time he came
close, her hands
holding him by the shoulders.
'It's raining hard.' Suddenly
there was a booming from the
wine slopes across the lake;
cannons were shooting at
hail-bearing clouds in
order to break them.
The lights of the promenade
went off, went on again.'
So we get that repetition of
that same visual detail--
the kissing, her face getting
very big as it
gets close to him.
So the repetition of
the same close-up.
And what is odd is that we get
exactly the same narrative
sequence after that close-up.
After the visual detail of her
face getting big, we get the
exact switch to a different
narrative register.
So this is not Nicole passing
judgment on him.
So it's not exactly the
same structure as the
incident with Rosemary.
But there's a switch, abrupt
switch, to a different
sequence of narrative.
In this case, it's such
quite a trivial event.
They were shooting cannons
in order to break up the
hail-bearing clouds.
I guess it's something you
do in Switzerland.
But the point is that cannons
were being fired in peacetime
Switzerland, which is kind of
a surprising fact in itself
since we're not so familiar with
cannons being fired for
that purpose.
But given the fact that we'll be
seeing the intertwined, the
superimposed images of love
and war, the firing of the
cannons is certainly not
trivial at this point.
So at the very least, we can say
that there's an intrusion
into this love scene of the
undeniable and historical
proven reality of war, of World
War I. It's just a fact
of history that there
was such a war.
So Fitzgerald's not going to
recreate that war for us,
except for going over the
battleground and talking about
it taking 20 lives to
advance a foot--
that reference that
we saw last time.
He's not going to go further in
the direction of World War
I than he has done so far.
But he is going to give us
echoes of World War I in
civilian situations.
And not only that, but he's
going to use that as a
narrative follow up to a love
scene, specifically to a
close-up when the woman's face
is getting bigger and bigger.
So we can say that what the
close-up is doing for
Fitzgerald--
especially the woman's face
getting bigger and bigger--
is the dramatization, the
visualization of the woman's
power over the man.
So when Rosemary's face is
getting so big that she fills
the entire visual tableau, that
is the point where we see
that Rosemary actually knows
exactly what kind of a man
Dick Diver is.
That's she's is absolutely
clear-eyed about him.
Here there's not that equivalent
clear-eyed
judgement from the part
of Nicole because
she's still a patient.
She hasn't gotten to
that point yet.
But Fitzgerald is giving us the
structural equivalent of
that kind of judgment in the
sense that there's a sudden
break up of the love scene and
the replacement of that love
scene by something that is like
an intonation of battle.
So at the very least, we should
be prepared for the
fact that maybe war is not
extraneous to love.
Maybe war is actually
organic to love.
That maybe war is the narrative
structure of love.
That love takes the form of a
battle between the two people
who are conjoined
in this fashion.
So this is, in many ways, a kind
of a prelude to a kind of
visual tableau that is a gesture
towards the future of
that narrative.
But I want to look at another
technique now, which is also
very prominent and very
unmistakable in Tender Is the
Night, which is the technique
of cross-cutting.
So this is in book 2 of Tender
Is the Night, and especially
in section 10 of book 2.
So it's the beginning
of section 10.
Begins with, "In Zurich in
September Doctor Diver had tea
with Baby Warren."
So at this point, he's
still a doctor.
And it's in that professional
capacity that he would have
tea with Baby Warren, Nicole's
sister, who's trying to get a
doctor to take of her.
Buy a doctor for Nicole.
So they're having tea and
talking about various things.
And he's still not agreeing to
being a lifelong caretaker for
Nicole at this point.
But this is what happens on
page 158, one page down.
Next page, actually.
We get a sudden, abrupt switch
to Nicole's point of view,
told from her point of view, and
narrated by Nicole herself
as in the first person.
This is outside of her exchange
of the letters that
she writes to Dick Diver.
We'll get a sense of how Nicole
thinks by following
this kind of monologue that is
given to us as counterpoint to
the tea between Dick Diver
and Baby Warren.
"How do you do, lawyer.
We're going to Como tomorrow
for a week and
then back to Zurich.
That's why I wanted you and
sister to settle this, because
it doesn't matter to us
how much I'm allowed.
We're going to live very quietly
in Zurich for two
years and Dick has enough
to take care of us.
No, Baby, I'm more practical
than you think--
It's only for clothes and
things I'll need it...
Why, that's more than--
can the estate really afford
to give me all that?
I know I'll never manage
to spend it.
Do you have that much?
Why do you have more--
is it because I'm supposed
to be incompetent?
All right.
Let my share pile up then...
No, Dick refuses to
have anything
whatever to do with it.
I'll have to feel bloated
for us both..."
I'm not even reading
it very well.
This could have been read much
better to get the tone exactly
what a sharp businesswoman
Nicole is.
In the space of one
short exchange she
achieves three things.
She manages to get her
share of the estate.
So she begins with saying, OK,
we can live very modestly on
Dick's pay.
We don't need the money.
I just need it for clothes
and incidentals.
So very modest requirement,
very modest
demand on the estate.
She gets the amount she
says is too much.
She checks out to see how much
Baby is getting and finds out
that, in fact, what she's
getting is less
than what Baby gets.
So she gets an increase right
then and there on the spot.
More than that, there's, of
course, the question whether
Dick will have a share
of that income.
And she's admitting to the fact
that she would have to
feel bloated for the two of
them, that he's not going to
get a penny of that income.
So in the space of one paragraph
that switch from
Dick's point of view to Nicole's
point of view is, in
fact, an incredible fast forward
of the narrative,
changing our conception of
Nicole from a patient in a
mental institution to a sharp
business woman who is going to
keep very, very tight control
over the money
that comes to her.
That we shouldn't forget,
after all, she's the
granddaughter of a man who has
a huge fortune, who has made
that huge fortune.
And there's a constant
reference, as in For Whom the
Bell Tolls, the cross-generation
link to the
grandfather.
In Tender is the Night,
there's also a
cross-generational link to
Nicole's grandfather.
That maybe she's more her
grandfather's granddaughter
than we may think.
So the effect of that
cross-cutting is to take the
narrative away from Dick's side
of the story and deposit
the agency strictly
on Nicole's side.
That she's the one who's
actually calling the shots.
She's the one who actually has
the financial control over the
future of that marriage.
Let me just give you one other
much more small incidence of
that cross-cutting.
All this, the many pages after
that cross-cutting, is told in
the first person in
Nicole's voice.
And so from being in a mental
institution, suddenly she's
married to Dick Diver.
All of that is settled.
She has the control
over the money.
But she also is beginning to
complain about the particular
shape the marriage is taking.
"But I was gone again by that
time-- trains and beaches they
were all one.
That was why he took me
travelling but after my second
child, my little girl,
Topsy, was born
everything got dark again....
If I could get word to my
husband who has seen fit to
desert me here, to leave me in
the hands of incompetents.
You tell me my baby is black--
that's farcical, that's
very cheap.
We went to Africa merely to see
Timgad, since my principal
interest in life
is archaeology.
I am tired of knowing nothing
and being reminded of it all
the time."
So page 161.
We can see the speed of this
development, of that
particular interpretation
of the marriage.
From the beginning, when she's
not even married to Dick
Diver, to the next page, 159,
when she's married to him, but
retaining full control of her
finances, to page 161 when
she's in a position to
complain about his
behavior as a husband.
And what is odd here--
and I think it's actually quite
heavy handed on the part
of Fitzgerald-- is that, once
again, there's a gratuitous,
completely inexplicable
intrusion of a racialized
detail in the person of Nicole's
daughter, Topsy.
That "my baby is black" is
really coming out of nowhere,
except for the fact that we
know that Fitzgerald has a
long history of racializing
particular characters at
critical moments.
And you guys know that Topsy is
a reference to Uncle Tom's
Cabin, to Harriet Beecher
Stowe's novel.
And Topsy's a black character,
and it's one of the most vivid
black characters
in that novel.
So it's Fitzgerald's kind of
backhanded tribute to a
nineteenth century classic and
resurrecting the name of a
black character.
Totally inappropriate name for
the daughter of Nicole.
But nonetheless, that's what
he chooses to give her.
So this is just to flesh out the
features of the history of
racialization in Fitzgerald.
We know that there really are
no black characters in The
Great Gatsby.
But there's this constant
intrusion of
black characters, strangely.
"As we crossed Blackwell's
island a limousine passed us,
driven by a white chauffeur,
in which sat three modish
negroes, two bucks and a girl.
I laughed aloud as the yolks
of their eyeballs rolled
toward us in haughty rivalry."
So this is Gatsby going
to town with Nick.
And all of a sudden, the
intrusion of the three blacks
in a limousine driven by a white
chauffeur, that is a
kind of visual metaphor for the
upstart Gatsby trying to
elevate himself higher
than he should be.
In this case, the racialization
that we see in
Tender is the Night has to do,
I think, with a moment of
marital volatility.
We know that she actually
has control of the basic
structural feature of that
marriage, which is the money.
And given that control, she's
in a position to put a
particular spin on
that marriage.
And the marriage has to do with
neglect, with the fact
that they're traveling because
he needs to travel, that she's
an involuntary appendage to his
constant travel, and that
he's neglecting her.
So this is, in many ways, a
very early paving of the
ground for the eventual outcome
of the novel, that is
highlighted by Nicole presenting
herself as the
victimized party in
the marriage.
So to racialize herself and to
racialize her daughter is a
very specific and I guess
tested technique of
demonstration a degree of
grievance, a degree of felt
oppression on her part.
Even though she's not really
black, it's almost as if she
were the black person
in that marriage.
So that's what the metaphor
is doing for her.
She's anything but black.
But she's treated as
if she were black.
That's what she's claiming.
So we don't really know if
we agree with her yet.
But this is Nicole's
interpretation of the marriage
is that she is the oppressed
party in that marriage.
So let's look at one
other instance of
cross-cutting to Nicole.
And this is, once again, taking
the narrative agency--
at least landing the story
on Nicole's side.
"Dick, why did you register Mr.
and Mrs. Diver instead of
Doctor and Mrs. Diver?
I just wondered--
it just floated through
my mind. --
You've taught me that work is
everything and I believe you.
You used to say a man knows
things and when he stops
knowing things he's like anybody
else, and the thing is
to get power before he
stops knowing things.
If you want to turn topsy-turvy,
all right, but
must your Nicole follow you
walking on her hands,
darling?"
So I think that by page 162,
one page further down, the
shape of what is to come is
pretty much unmistakable.
And it is conveyed very much
through a tone of voice.
Through, in this case, almost
a repetition of exactly the
same kind of structure
that we're seeing
between Dick and Rosemary.
Rosemary is the one, who on
page 105 already has seen
through Dick Diver.
She has seen through him so
that she can pass the most
wounding judgment on
him that he's not
doctor, he's an actor.
Nicole has arrived at that
conclusion on page 162 that he
is not a doctor.
A doctor is supposed to have
medical knowledge.
That's what makes a
medical doctor.
A medical doctor is
that he has more
knowledge than his patient.
But she knows at this point
that, in fact, he doesn't have
any more knowledge than the
average person, that he's lost
his claim to being a doctor.
And so there are not that many
more identities available to
him once he's lost that claim
to a professional identity.
She's not saying outright that
he's an actor, but she's
implying as much.
And that added detail about
his well-being turned
topsy-turvy as well as the
naming the thing, that the
thing is to get power before
he stops knowing things.
It is naming exactly what
it is that Dick Diver
has failed to do.
If he had done things right,
he would have had absolute
control of the marriage before
he loses out in the department
of knowledge.
But now that he's lost out in
the department of knowledge,
he's not going to have power
in that marriage as well.
So the very sharp, clear-eyed,
absolutely unsentimental
judgment of her husband is
very much an echo of what
Rosemary has intuited
much earlier.
And it comes over to us, comes
across to the reader, once
again, through the technique
of cross-cutting.
So I would say that this sort
of the emptying out of any
kind of sustenance, of any moral
sustenance in Dick Diver
has come very, very early.
And it's through this complete,
steady erosion of
any admiration for him on the
part of two women who started
out as great idolizers of him.
So now we've gotten to a point
where we actually see the
speed of the negative resolution
picking up.
The speed becomes just
faster and faster.
Basically, there's three points
of no return for Dick
Diver on his way to losing his
medical practice in Rockport.
The first point of no return
is the fight he gets with a
carabinieri.
"He walked past the staring
carabinieri and up to the
grinning face, hit it with a
smashing left beside the jaw.
The man dropped to the floor."
This is a cab driver that he
got into a fight with.
"For a moment he stood over him
in triumph-- but even as
the first pang of doubt shot
through him the world reeled;
he was clubbed down, and fists
and boots beat on him in a
strange tattoo.
He felt his nose break like a
shingle and his eyes jerk as
if they had snapped back on a
rubber band into his head.
A rib splintered under
a stamping heel.
Momentarily he lost
consciousness, regained it as
he was raised to a sitting
position and his wrists jerked
together with handcuffs.
The plainclothes lieutenant whom
he had knocked down...
poised himself, drew back his
arm and smashed him to the
floor."
This is a very brutal scene.
Lots of people getting shot.
And Dick Diver, it's important
to point out, is not exempt
from that violence.
And this is the first
emptying out of his
professional identity.
That a doctor is supposed to
be treating someone who has
been subjected to that
kind of violence.
And instead, it turns out that
he is the one who needs a
doctor to take care of him.
So this is what happens when you
have things happening very
fast. And this is an image,
actually, of the carabenieri,
which still is kind of
sinister looking.
But this is the person-- the
gang of them, actually--
beating up on Dick Diver.
So what is interesting is that
even though things are
actually happening, raining down
fast, thick and fast on
Dick Diver, he's actually
accused of moving too fast. We
see that various people accuse
him of various things.
We've seen Rosemary is accusing
him of something,
Nicole accusing him
of something.
And he's now being accused by
his partner in a clinic in
this conversation between
Franz and his wife.
"'For shame!' Kaethe said.
'You're the solid one,
you do the work.
It's a case or hare and tortoise
-- and in my opinion
the hare's race is
almost done'...
Franz let himself believe with
ever-increasing conviction
that Dick travelled
intellectually and emotionally
at such a rate of speed that
the vibrations jarred him."
So the two of them talking
behind his back, saying that
he's not such a great partner
to begin with.
And we see the consequence of
that kind of conversation
between Franz and his wife when
they're talking about
dissolving that medical
partnership.
"'This is no go,' he
said suddenly.
'Well, that's occurred to
me,' Franz admitted.
'Your heart isn't
in this project
anymore, Dick.' 'I know.
I want to leave-- we should
strike some arrangement about
taking Nicole's money out
gradually.' 'I have thought
about that too, Dick--
I have seen this coming.
I'm able to arrange other
backing, and it will be
possible to take all your money
out by the end of the
year. ' Dick had not intended
to come to a decision so
quickly, nor was he prepared
for Franz's so ready
acquiescence in the break,
yet he was relieved.
Not without desperation he had
long felt the ethics of his
profession dissolving into
a lifeless mass."
So this is the speed
of the break up of
that medical practice.
Again, at a speed that Dick had
not counted on, that he
had not asked for.
It is somebody else's speed
that has dictated the
narrative development.
I know that we're almost running
out of time, so I'll
give you the final part of that
resolution against in
fast motion.
Actually, I'm going to skip
this, because I know that
we're running out of time.
So this will be on
the PowerPoint.
But I'm just going to go to
the very end of narrative
about love as war.
We've being seeing this super
imposition of love and World
War I all the way through.
And finally, we see the
intrusion of World War I into
this description of Nicole's
idea of what
the marriage is like.
"Again she struggled with it,
fighting him with her small,
fine eyes, with the plush
arrogance of a top dog, with
her nascent transference to
another man, with the
accumulated resentment of years;
she fought him with her
money and her faith that her
sister disliked him and was
behind her now; with the thought
of the new enemies he
was making with his
bitterness...
For this inner battle she used
even her weaknesses--
fighting bravely and
courageously with the old cans
and crockery and bottles,
empty receptacles of her
expiated sins, outrages,
mistakes.
And suddenly, in the space of
two minutes she achieved her
victory and justified herself
to herself without lie or
subterfuge, cut the
cord forever."
Two minutes for her to
come to the final
decision about her marriage.
And this is the final image.
I was just saying this is a
great moment to pair up with
the barber scene, the
rape scene in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
"The mirror in front of Nicole
reflected the passage between
the men's side and the women's,
and Nicole started up
at the sight of Tommy, Bob and
the man she's going to marry
entering and wheeling sharply
in the men's shop.
She knew with a flush of joy
that there was going to be
some kind of showdown.
In a minute Dick came into
Nicole's booth, his expression
emerging annoyed from behind
a towel of his
hastily rinsed face.
'Your friend has worked himself
up into a state.
He wants to see us together,
so I agreed to
have it over with.
Come along!' 'But my hair-- it's
half cut.' 'Nevermind--
come along!' Resentfully she
had the staring coiffeuse
remove the towels.
Feeling messy and unadorned
she followed
Dick from the hotel.
Outside Tommy bent
over her hand.
'We'll go to the Cafe des
Alliees,' said Dick."
So the same barber shop scene.
The same cutting of the hair,
except that in this case, the
hair is only half cut.
It is the speed of
that resolution--
the marriage has ended so
hastily that the hair cutting
job is not even completely
done.
But that's the story that
Fitzgerald wants to tell, this
hastily done job.